Seattle's mayor says it's a miracle that
a mother and her baby girl survived a
deadly crane collapse dramatic dashcam
video shows the moment that the crane
came crashing down at Google's new
campus in Seattle on Saturday four
people were killed including college
student Sara Wong and ironworker travis
corbett four others were hurt the 25
year old mother and her four month-old
daughter made it out of this car oh wow
with only minor Janet shamlian is near
the scene Janet good morning John good
morning as construction booms here in
Seattle it's become known as the
nation's crane capital with more of them
up than in any other US city and it's
been relatively safe this is the first
deadly accident here in more than a
dozen years this morning the road behind
me where it happened has just been
reopened and Seattle's mayor is among
those vowing to get to the bottom of
this horrific incident multiple calls
reporting falling from the roof onto
multiple cars witnesses say it sounded
like an earthquake when a crane
collapsed onto Google's new under
construction headquarters Saturday
hitting six cars on one of Seattle's
busiest streets it was so loud that you
felt it right so I mean the ground shook
when it hits and and it just to iron
workers inside the crane were killed
along with two people in separate cars
Bruce cashmere and his son took this
time-lapse video of the crane just
before it fell he said it was being
disassembled by workers next thing
Kabang danshi come and on you what it
was there is no known cause yet but wind
gusts at the time were as high as 23
miles per hour there was a huge gust of
very strong gust just before this
Seattle has around 60 active cranes more
than any other US city and roughly
double the number in Portland or Chicago
the Department of Labor reports between
2011 and 2015 there was an average of 44
crane related deaths each year in the US
but none of them were in Seattle we're
really at the beginning of an
investigation that will likely take
months
Tim church is with the washing
Department of Labor he promised to learn
the cause so it won't happen again no
one should ever have to go to work and
not come home from their job four
companies are now under investigation in
connection with the incident the real
estate firm Vulcan that manages the site
expressed its sympathies to those who
lost loved ones the general contractor
did the same and said it is cooperating
with authorities but the question many
are asking this morning with these
cranes dotting the Seattle skyline how
can they be sure that the others are
safe Anthony
44 crane related deaths a year
surprisingly high number Janna thank you
very much